des cailloux dans la chaussure histoire
d'une lutte citoyenne très beau film
signé Michael damperons qui replace le
citoyen au cœur des décisions politiques
et économiques qui montrent en tout cas
une envie citoyenne de se réapproprier
son espace et de ne pas laisser les
autres décider à sa place le citoyen
est-il en train de rebattre les cartes
du jeu politique du système tel qu'il
s'est construit pendant des décennies et
bien nous allons en parler avec nos
invités bernard-lui bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur RDPI de la Drôme RDPI c'est la
majorité présidentielle et la Drôme
c'est précisément le département de
Saint-Nazaire-en-Royans où a été tourné
ce documentaire donc vous connaissez
bien le dossier vous êtes également je
le précise vice-président de la
commission des affaires économiques au
Sénat Jean-Pierre Mignard bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes avocat au
barreau de Paris essayiste maître de
conférence à Sciences Po parmi vos très
nombreuses casquettes celle de
conseiller de différents responsables
politiques et vous avez été un des
premiers à porter l'idée de démocratie
participative notamment pendant la
campagne présidentielle de Ségolène
Royal et c'est important à préciser pour
le sujet qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
Thierry baudet bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes président du CESU
Conseil économique social et
environnemental et vous êtes l'auteur de
ce livre repoussons les frontières de la
démocratie paru aux Éditions de l'Aube
Delphine Jouenne bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes directrice du média
a priori cofondatrice d'Ender be un
cabinet de conseil en communication et
influence et vous venez de publier ce
livre démostalgie de la rupture du
citoyen avec le politique je précise
parce que là aussi c'est important pour
notre débat aujourd'hui que vous avez
aussi une casquette des lieux municipale
tout à fait c'est important ce film
c'est vraiment le combat d'un village
mais que nous dit-il sur la façon dont
les citoyens voient aujourd'hui la vie
de la cité Thierry baudet qu'ils n'en
peuvent plus des décisions verticales
c'est un peu ce qui ressort de ce film
ce qu'on ressent après l'avoir vu ce
qu'on ressent et que moi je trouve
extrêmement positif et encourageant
c'est que même si nos concitoyens sont
de plus en plus nombreux euh apprendre
de la distance avec les grands rites
démocratiques notamment les dimanches
d'élection il manifeste leur envie
d'être acteurs des sujets qui les
concernent et ça ça me paraît très
important on parle souvent de crise de
la démocratie moi je considère qu'en
réalité s'il y a chris est une crise de
croissance de la démocratie nous sommes
dans des sociétés éduquées avec beaucoup
d'informations et voilà c'est ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle nous concitoyens
veulent être acteurs des sujets qui les
concernent ils veulent être associés aux
décisions qui les concernent ils veulent
participer à leur co-construction ce qui
veut dire qu'ils veulent de
l'horizontalité aussi Delphine joindre
c'est ce qu'on ressent après ce oui
après je modérais peut-être un petit peu
ce point parce que finalement on se rend
compte qu'il se mobilise contre souvent
plus contre un projet que pour et
finalement on les retrouve pas forcément
à l'initiative justement dès lors qu'il
y a la possibilité aussi de prendre part
à la ville de la cité en étant peut-être
candidat aux élections municipales donc
c'est vrai que cette énergie qui est
extrêmement positive et il faut la
reconnaître il faut la saluer il
faudrait qu'on arrive aussi à réfléchir
à la façon dont on peut finalement
l'associer dès le départ à la
construction finalement des prospects en
réaction à quelque chose justement
exactement et vous Bernard lui c'est
vrai que c'est quand même un film où on
voit des citoyens refuser qu'on leur
impose des décisions d'en haut
évidemment on ne peut que penser à la
verticalité qui est souvent reprochée à
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que c'est un peu
une réaction à cela ces années où on a
dit que c'était le pouvoir était trop
vertical est-ce que vous l'avez pris
comme ça moi je l'ai pris en fait comme
l'exercice d'un pouvoir solitaire de la
part du maire précédent puisque personne
y compris dans son équipe n'avait
connaissance de l'ampleur de la carrière
qui allait être mise en place il faut
dire que sur le territoire des carrières
il y en a de partout donc les gens sont
habitués à ce paysage ici ce qui a été
surprenant c'est en fait au dernier
moment les gens ont découvert le projet
de carrière c'était au mois de janvier
les élections étaient en mars donc tout
de suite il s'est monté une association
et je dis que là où ça a été remarquable
c'est que cette association a réuni de
gens de tout bord de tout bord politique
mais aussi sociologiquement très
différent vous aviez chacun qui avait sa
compétence et c'est cette compétences
des uns et des autres qui a permis de
mettre un exergue quelques points qui
ont mobilisé derrière le voisin le
copain et la famille parce que beaucoup
de personnes n'avaient pas conscience de
ce qui allait se passer ni de l'ampleur
des dégâts qui allaient être apportés
qui allait dans le sens du maire donc on
sent quand même que ces citoyens
comprennent qu'une décision très
importante pour leur quotidien va être
prise et valeur être imposée et c'est ça
qu'il refuse parce que ça vient
des personnes de tout bord et de
compétences différentes chacun a pu
s'approprier le dossier parce que 800
pages personne peut ses approprier et
donc chacun a décortiqué en fonction de
son œil et justement quand on a vu la
réunion avec le commissaire enquêteur on
a vu les énormités qui étaient
présentées et que ça soit par exemple
une étude hydraulique qui n'avait pas
été faite quand on voit que l'eau qui
peut être une réserve et été colorée
quand il y a eu des études
complémentaires donc les gens ont montré
du doigt et quand on voit que le
commissaire enquêteur bon ça m'a fait
bondir a fait un copier-coller entre
Saint-Nazaire le désert et Saint-Nazaire
en Royans on se dit vraiment même si les
mal payés il a dit dans son petit
reportage parce qu'il se trompe dedans
de ville donc il sait pas vraiment
approprié c'est exactement et donc là je
pense que ça remobilisé aussi la
population à réagir et à se dire
derrière mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait et
derrière il y a eu des élections une
partie de personnes qui ont été élues
étaient issues en fait de l'association
qui s'était mise en place et derrière
ils ont fait le grand chelem puisque
tous ont été élus il y a le cas de ce
village mais Jean-Pierre Mignard c'est
aussi un documentaire qui nous touche
parce que quelque part il a l'air de
refléter une envie générale de moins de
verticalité de plus d'horizontalité de
démocratie participative de citoyens qui
s'empare de leur espace alors là en
l'occurrence dans l'espace vraiment
local mais on a le sentiment que c'est
plus général c'est aussi votre sentiment
oui c'est plus général je remercie pour
ce que tu vous venez de dire parce que
ça signifie aussi que les gens
réagissent quand ils sont informés
exactement il y a la source de tout il y
a l'information le projet quel est-il et
quels sont la part de nuisances il aura
sur la vie quotidienne et collective
alors peut-être en effet dans ce cas-là
est-on trop localiste mais c'est alors
est-ce qu'on va réapprendre la
démocratie à travers cette ce mouvement
qui est assez exceptionnel je le
reconnais et sur un temps très bref en
réalité avec des interventions des
personnes qui quelquefois sont quasiment
nature expertale c'est très très
impressionnant travailler donc ça
signifie une chose d'abord c'est que les
citoyens
sont capables nos concitoyens sont cas
nous en sommes capables on va pas
s'exclure nous en sommes capables
comment est-ce que nous pouvons faire de
ses capacités
d'abord une action sur le plan local de
quels outils avons-nous besoin parce que
quand même là c'est pas seulement
l'information c'est une privation des
outils qui permettait effectivement de
mettre
ça c'est un vrai je pense non la
discussion et comment tu l'as tout ça
peut se transporter au niveau au niveau
national c'est c'est majeur peut-être
que vous avez la clé ce que vous avez
dit à un moment vous avez dit c'était
transpartie voilà alors c'est vrai qu'il
y a des formules démocratiques qui
supposent que d'une certaine manière on
laisse son habit politique ou politicien
je préfère politique péjoratif à la à la
porte pour reconstruire une pensée
publique à partir de ce que chacun pense
et de l'expérience commune des autres
parler de manque d'information ce que ce
que les habitants ne supportent pas dans
cette affaire c'est d'avoir été mis au
pied du mur et qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
consultation mais aussi d'avoir été un
peu pris pour des idiots et même d'avoir
été trahie d'après eux ce projet de
carrière n'avait pas été annoncé
clairement écoutez
en novembre 2019 j'ai vu passer un
encart dans le bulletin municipal et
c'est un total de 15 lignes où il est
question de projet raisonnés à la mesure
du village en accord avec la charte du
Parc Naturel Régional du Vercors
vraiment un truc mais leur minimiser
jusqu'au bout des ongles j'ai le texte
on peut le retrouver pour aller voir à
l'image c'est un truc de malade on nous
dit oui depuis le temps qu'on vous en
parle depuis 2017 personne a réagi bah
ouais attends en 2017 c'était trois
coupelles et là on arrive en
2020 en janvier
et c'est 90 000 tonnes avec une latitude
de 40%
finalement nous opposer à ce type
d'installation je partage je pense que
c'est surtout la phase de d'enquête qui
doit être restaurée pour être autre
chose que la simple légitimation de
l'action publique mais par exemple je
sais pas cette carrière est-ce qu'elle
était si indispensable là parce que vous
voyez on ne s'interroge jamais sur
l'objet du projet les citoyens nous
sommes nous sommes interrogés pour sur
les effets sur les conséquences mais
jamais une question de s'interroger sur
après tout ce projet est-il fondé une
carrière pourrait-elle ailleurs
c'est-à-dire que le projet est admis
cette atémique c'est un totem on ne
bouge plus du projet alors je pense
qu'il faudrait sur ce point avoir la
possibilité d'interroger alors ce point
les propriétaires les entrepreneurs vous
êtes sûr d'être là parce que ce qu'on
voit c'est quels sont vos choix quelles
sont vos études d'impact qu'avez-vous
fait parce que on découvre avec ce que
font les citoyens eux-mêmes il y a des
conséquences monumentales et d'ailleurs
je à l'origine le préfet devrait même
intégrer ce qui veut dire que ce serait
envisagé dans toute la chaîne en amont
d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est si utile que
ça ici voilà ça excusez-moi c'est on
change on est plus simplement pour faire
révérence ou protester parce que c'est
ça mais on est dire est-ce que c'est si
utile que ça et Thierry baudet moi je
pense que ce dernier point est très
important le moment où on associe ou au
consulte les citoyens me paraît très
important et en fait nos concitoyens ils
ont compris que la plupart de temps ce
qu'on appelle concertation ça vise en
réalité à essayer d'obtenir un accord
sur un projet qui a déjà été conçu et
décidé et et donc ce n'est pas vécu
comme une démarche sincère a fortiori
quand on sort les concertations pour
sortir d'une situation de crise toute
référence à une actualité politique
n'est pas totalement fortuite donc on
c'est pour ça le point que vous
soulignez tout à l'heure est important
parce que là on est dans de la
participation citoyenne qui se mobilise
en un projet qu'on veut imposer aux
populations mais on peut très bien
imaginer que la participation citoyenne
demain elle interviennent beaucoup plus
en amont au moment où les projets
émergent où là il ne s'agirait pas comme
dans les concertations qu'on connaît à
chercher à créer de l'alignement mais au
contraire à essayer de donner de
l'assise et des points d'appui pour des
politiques publiques qui en puisent qui
ensuite puis cette mieux comprise parce
que partager et donc mieux accepter de
faire confiance en son peuple et c'est
peut-être pas le cas de nos responsables
politiques peut-être ont-ils manque-t-il
de confiance en nous vous savez c'est
toujours été l'histoire de la démocratie
il y a toujours eu une une réserve le il
y a eu des luttes est-ce que finalement
la parole
d'un simple habitant de la commune à la
même valeur que la parole d'un prix
Nobel ou ou d'un expert c'est un vrai
sujet moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui
finalement dans la situation
démocratique dans laquelle nous sommes
il ne s'agit combattant j'allais dire de
faire participer davantage de mondes à
notre question démocratique se pose
encore la question du vote des étrangers
aux élections locales mais moi ce pour
moi l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de faire
en sorte que tous les joueurs rejouent à
nouveau on se satisfait trop
finalement
de d'un taux d'abstention très élevé on
se satisfait trop de citoyens qui sont
en marge et pour moi une démocratie
vigoureuse c'est une démocratie qui
cherche les voix et moyen pour faire
sortir le plus de monde possible
j'allais dire de la sphère privée pour
rejoindre l'Agora public mais en même
temps pardon cette question lorsque nous
votons et peut-être Bernard bi vous
allez vous pouvoir réagir c'est aussi
pour déléguer c'est aussi parce que nous
n'avons pas le temps de nous occuper des
affaires de la cité nous les laissons à
d'autres et nous leur faisons confiance
au départ le vote c'est pour ça oui
c'est la démocratie
représentative des citoyens on a un
projet et là on en a exactement
l'exemple puisque le projet l'A qui a
monté sa liste électorale elle a été
élue sur un projet c'était se battre
contre la carrière alors que le maire
précédent vous avez vu c'était même pas
un entre filet dans son bulletin
municipal c'était la carrière se fait
c'était un acquis
de certains politiques avec un manque
d'eau transparent avec le carrier qui a
présenté son projet en fait les 840
pages ça a été présenté à personne il a
fallu que ça soit le commissaire
enquêteur qui vient de dire quelques
bribes mais dans les communes
environnantes le carrier s'est contenté
de poser le dossier de 840 pages auprès
du bureau de la secrétaire de mairie
sans même le présenter au maire des
communes voisines donc il y a vraiment
eu un manque de concertation et je pense
que c'était un processus qui existait ce
que je vous le dis sur le secteur
c'était l'habitude d'avoir des carriers
c'était pire pour le Jacques ils se
partagait les carrières et ils avaient
un besoin une carrière arriver à
échéance il cherchait un autre terrain
ils achetaient les terrains ce qui a été
fait ici d'ailleurs parce que le carré
était propriétaire des terrains sauf
qu'il y avait un bémol il avait oublié
qu'il y avait un chemin et que le chemin
était communal et qu'il peut pas acheter
que du coup il pouvait pas l'exploiter
donc ça peut-être été la faille qui a
permis au préfet de prendre son arrêté
négatif
ils avaient voté pour ce maire encore
une fois si on doit tous s'occuper de
toutes les affaires de la cité
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure de se
projeter et je pense que sur un projet
comme ça c'est important que la
postulation soit consultée il
éventuellement par un référendum local
même après l'élection même après
élection alors après il y avait le coût
de l'argent vous avez vu quand même ces
phénoménal quand on voit que le carrier
dédommagé entre guillemets pour tous les
inconvénients la défiguration tout ce
qu'on peut mettre derrière ces mots à
hauteur de 20.000 euros par an si vous
voyez sur 30 ans ce que ça représentait
et quand à la fin il demande 9 millions
de dommages et intérêts de préjudice ça
voulait dire que il allait gagner entre
guillemets 300000 euros quasiment sans
rien faire puisque là-dedans il ne tient
pas compte de l'exploitation donc il y a
quand même une disproportion et la
population bien montrée qu'on ne
l'achetait pas pour 20000 euros par an
même si ça permettait rénover le
centre-ville le centre-ville il peut
attendre ça c'est un message intéressant
aussi de la part de la population
publique les appelaient en quête de
commodité c'était donc sur ce point
c'était hyper formel d'ailleurs il
fallait que le projet plaise au roi soit
l'intérêt public voilà ça a duré très
longtemps écoutez moi je suis l'avocat
j'étais l'avocat de la commune de
Plogoff ce qui doit vous dire quelque
chose ça a été terrible il a fallu deux
trois mois
c'était un vrai semblable les Bretons
sont des gens qui tiennent c'est solide
quand ils sont dans la lande face à la
gendarmerie mobile je vous assure
c'était vraiment quelque chose il a
fallu une nuit d'émeutes à Quimper la
ville de Quimper avait été vraiment
incroyable des milliers de gens parce
que on voulait construire une centrale
nucléaire à la pointe du rat c'était
très bizarre ça c'était c'était la
préhistoire de DS c'est l'ancienne
direction d'EDF qui travaillait comme
une forteresse etc et il a donc il a
fallu que ce soit d'ailleurs la gauche
au pouvoir qui décide d'arrêter vous
rendez compte et c'était un des grands
dossiers d'ailleurs de pas une
présidentielle de François Mitterrand et
ça a été arrêté et puis il y a eu la loi
bouchardot je crois de 1983 sur la
démocratisation de l'enquête publique et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis est-ce
que ça génère jamais de la vie EDF a
construit ses centrales et monsieur qui
était pour il y avait ce qui était
contre mais jamais plus il n'y a eu
mensonge sur les intentions et en ce qui
concerne la trempe la transparence je
crois vraiment que le nucléaire français
avec le nucléaire américain sont parmi
les plus transparents et ils sont pas
ils m'ont même pris comme avocat après
ils étaient pas ils étaient pas
rancunier quand même mais c'était
typique de ce qu'il me fallait pas faire
donc comment associer les gens à la
décision et parce que qu'est-ce qui va
se passer là on a une mondialisation qui
s'arrête donc on va avoir effectivement
des exploitations qui vont devenir plus
difficile là on pensait en trouver il
peut y avoir j'en parlais tout à l'heure
avec mon associé il peut y avoir des
marchés tendus puisque c'est le Grand
Paris il y a besoin effectivement
d'aller vite donc on va chercher des
projets les plus rapides possibles
peut-être passer tout son temps
nécessaire à dire là ce serait peut-être
moins dangereux que là et là ça aurait
moins de convoyance si le marché très
tendu on aurait effectivement des
problèmes de cette nature de plus en
plus important et ça il faut faire très
attention parce que sinon on va penser
que le développement la croissance qui
sont nos mots magiques vont passer
surtout avant tout et pour tout et là on
aura des décrochages parce que le
décrochage il n'est là lorsqu'on dit la
croissance et le développement avant
tout et l'enquête d'utilité publique
après c'est c'est là où il va falloir
trouver une solution alors vous allez me
dire oui mais c'est bien gentil faut
bien qu'on continue à exploiter et avoir
une activité économique soit mais
maintenant il faut qu'on en connaisse le
prix et le prix politique le prix
politique on le sait aujourd'hui du non
participation d'une non élaboration des
projets des citoyens à cela se paye par
des absences au niveau électoral un
refus de la politique et alors après
vous vous allez dire les extrêmes les
extrêmes mais on les aura fabriqué les
extraits ce qui n'a pas été le cas dans
ce film puisque pendant tout le
documentaire on voit ses habitants se
battre avec les moyens dont ils
disposent le disant l'introduction donc
réunion publique manifestation
rassemblement très bonne enfant
d'ailleurs intervention dans les médias
et puis et puis la voix traditionnelle
politique les élections et c'est une
étape extrêmement intéressante pour
notre débat regardez
je suis pas un grand fan des
institutions et donc c'est évidemment
pas un système que je cautionne mais il
y avait le shunzu qui disait dans l'art
de la guerre de se tenir proche de ses
amis encore plus de ses ennemis déjà la
leçon à en retenir c'est que combattre
un système de l'extérieur en faisant
front tout seul face à une espèce de
mécanique parce qu'en réalité un système
institutionnel c'est plus des gens
c'est un système c'est à dire c'est
vraiment une mécanique et donc en fait
il y a qu'un crétin qui va les jeter
dans un rouage de deux tonnes en se
disant qu'il va l'arrêter quoi c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe il faut être
dans la machine faut être faut être l'un
des rouages
il faut dans la machine il faut
combattre le système de l'Intérieur
Delphine joinne c'est une méthode après
c'est quand même dommage d'en arriver à
des mots comme combattre système parce
que finalement la démocratie est quand
même quelque chose de fabuleux dans
laquelle on peut prendre tous par et le
fait par exemple moi je le vois au
niveau en tant que élu local sans
étiquette on a cette possibilité aussi
de pouvoir s'opposer s'affirmer avec
plus ou moins de succès mais c'est aussi
ça de se dire que finalement ce n'est
pas qu'un système c'est quelque chose
avec les avec lequel on peut vraiment
construire quelque chose qui peut être
aussi beau et qui n'est pas forcément
que dans le combat parce qu'il serait
fait en plus à l'art de la guerre
Thierry bodex ça montre que la il faut
faire vivre le désir de démocratie et on
parlait tout à l'heure de démocratie
représentative moi ce qui me frappe
c'est que quand on s'engage dans un
combat dans une lutte comme celle qui
qu'ils ont menée
on n'est pas dans une
concurrence des légitimités avec la
démocratie représentative on voit même
que ça peut y conduire et moi dans un
autre registre au plan national j'avais
été très frappé au Conseil économique
social environnemental c'était tenu une
convention citoyenne sur le climat sur
les 150 citoyens tirés au sort 15 en
suivant c'était présenté pour la
première fois de leur vie à des
élections dit voilà et donc ça peut
conduire ça peut conduire à à l'élection
et moi je pense qu'un point qui est très
très important la la démocratie
représentative bien sûr c'est centrales
mais c'est pas toute la démocratie la
démocratie ne se réduit pas l'élection
le citoyen ne se réduit pas à l'électeur
et il n'y a pas de concurrence moi je
pense au contraire que la démocratie
participative en associant les citoyens
à la construction des décisions ça peut
donner des points d'appui à celles et
ceux qui ont la légitimité de l'élection
et qui ont donc le dernier mot en
d'autres si le dernier mot appartient à
celles et ceux qui ont la légitimité de
l'élection sur de plus en plus de sujets
la construction de la décision il me
semble qu'elle appartient à la société
tout entière moi je partage totalement
ce que vous dites et dans un petit
village comme ça je comprends pas que
les gens n'aient pas été associés dès le
départ parce que c'était quand même le
baba autant dans une grande ville on
peut dire c'est difficile d'associer la
population dans un village de 1000
habitants je veux dire ça représente 250
familles tout le monde doit être au
courant et quand on voit que les
conseillers municipaux n'étaient pas
informés n'étaient pas au courant qu'il
y en a deux d'ailleurs qui sont
présentés avec la liste du maire et lui
avec Rémi sodach bon ben c'est quand
même qu'il y avait eu un problème
d'homme seul on va dire ça comme ça
après c'est important aussi ce que vous
dites parce que vous avez vu il y a une
dame qui a dit c'est la première fois
qu'elle s'engageait en politique c'est
quand même très intéressant les gens
sont allés voter massivement c'était
quand même pendant la période qui
précédait le confinement il y a eu une
participation
vraiment extraordinaire donc les gens se
sont appropriés à démocratie à ce
moment-là et après il faut la faire
vivre avec des outils très classique de
la politique à l'ancienne avec des
banderoles des manifestations des
interventions dans les médias qu'on
pourrait complètement qualifier de
lobbying le mot est un peu le genre de
choses qu'on doit pouvoir faire
régulièrement pendant les six ans d'un
mandat sur des sujets de cette
importance bien sûr lorsqu'on va rénover
un trottoir on va pas forcément le dire
mais quand on rénove un centre village
je pense que c'est des choses qu'il
faudrait informer davantage la
population et ce qui se fait peu souvent
dans nos villages c'est souvent des
informations postes post projet c'est à
dire que le projet va être défini dans
le dans le programme du candidat et il
va y avoir une réunion d'information qui
va être mise en place mais pendant cette
réunion d'information elle est
simplement là pour convaincre ou
rassurer mais n'est pas du tout là pour
être une une remise en cause ou une
réflexion collective sur la pertinence
du projet
disent toujours c'est de l'activité
économique c'est de l'emploi c'est des
rentrées fiscales il toujours sur ce
point une partie du cerveau qu'à toute
une série de bonnes intentions pour dire
et puis il y a de la part de certains
élus mais je le comprends parce que si
je me mettais à leur place ce serait un
dilemme et de dire oui mais là je vais
quand même assurer plus de moyens à ma
commune je vais bon et puis l'autre côté
je sais je ne veux pas voir il n'y a
plus je ne vois que d'un œil et cetera
donc vous voyez c'est-à-dire comment par
quel surmoi le corps social les citoyens
nous allons effectivement décider que
toute croissance n'est pas bonne je suis
pas un décroissant mais surtout que
toute croissance est bonne à condition
qu'elle soit associée à un certain
nombre de critères et que ces critères
soient validés par les personnes
notamment dans les villes dans les
communes dans les choix parce que il
s'agit pas quelquefois de refuser il
s'agit d'aménager il s'agit d'avoir un
cahier des charges est-ce que c'est
possible lorsqu'on écoute les arguments
de tout le monde est-ce qu'on peut
encore mettre en place des projets moi
je crois vraiment qu'il faut savoir
perdre du temps pour en gagner en
quelque sorte sur des sujets comme ça il
faut prendre le temps de poser les
termes du débat
d'identifier les nœuds de poser les
controverses et ce qui signifie pas qu'à
la fin tout le monde sera d'accord mais
si on a fait ce travail-là sincèrement
la décision qui est prise elle est
davantage éclairée elle est davantage
légitime moi ça me paraît vraiment ça me
paraît vraiment
utile et et on voit pardon moi ce qui
frappant dans dans le film c'est que
ça revient la question que vous posiez
tout à l'heure vous avez vu ce parcours
de compétences de la population c'est à
dire que nos concitoyens sont capables
j'allais dire de prendre des positions
éclairées sur des sujets y compris qui
sont les sujets difficiles
qui a dit alors j'ai renoté sa phrase
exprès la démocratie ce n'est pas
forcément être d'accord il faut en
discuter ça rejoint pleinement ce que
vous dites
dans ce film la lutte citoyenne
dans ce film la lutte citoyenne s'opère
par des voix légales et les choses n'ont
pas été plus loin mais on sait et on le
voit dans l'actualité que les
oppositions au projet peuvent se
terminer de façon absolument tragique on
en a encore un exemple récent à Sainte
Soline il y a en ce moment un projet
d'autoroute Toulouse Castres qui est
très contesté auditionné au Sénat Gérard
Darmanin a déclaré qu'il existait je le
cite 42 projets contestés sur le
territoire il y aura dit-il des volontés
d'installer des ADDES d'organiser des
manifestations extrêmement violentes
contre les forces de l'ordre et c'est
intéressant parce que dans ce
documentaire on entend ici et là des
tout petits débuts de radicalisation si
j'ose dire possible et c'est peut-être
un enseignement sur la façon dont les
choses peuvent dégénérer
à l'origine j'avais un rapport à la loi
d'une extrême obéissance mes parents se
moquaient de moi parce que je refusais
de traverser en dehors des clous voilà
aujourd'hui même si ma base c'est de
respecter la loi j'admets l'idée de la
désobéissance civile déjà
alors se pose le problème justement
jusqu'où on va
est-ce qu'on en a le droit est-ce que
voilà et en fait c'est une arme c'est
une des armes qui est possible
pour
contrecarrer un projet qu'on croit
injuste oui c'est crucial ce que dit
cette femme elle est en train de dire
qu'elle a toujours été dans la légalité
et que là ça y est elle commence un peu
à basculer donc c'est compliqué parce
que ça veut dire que ça peut vite
dégénérer la radicalisation arrive vite
en l'occurrence dans ce projet il n'a
pas eu lieu donc les habitants étaient
heureux mais quand ce n'est pas le cas
ça peut vite dégénérer je pense que il a
pas eu lieu aussi parce que ça n'a pas
dégénéré il faut je prends un peu sous
l'angle inverse parce que ça a été
vraiment une appropriation locale il n'y
a pas eu de personnes quelques personnes
des communes voisines mais pas eu de
personnes étrangères au secteur qui sont
venus et souvent quand on a des
personnes étrangères au secteur qui
viennent ils ne connaissent pas comme la
population pouvait le connaître les
tenants les aboutissants et donc là ça
dégénère parce qu'on met en avant autre
chose c'est une opposition systématique
sans connaissance alors que là vraiment
les gens avaient les arguments pour
influer au bon moment oui mais qu'est-ce
qui se serait passé s'il n'avait pas
obtenu gain de cause est-ce que certains
ce serait radicalisés
après je pense que ça
parce que le but c'était justement que
ça sera radicalise pas et qu'on obtienne
cause
il faut il faut réputer les gens de
bonne foi parce que si on dit il y a des
gens qui pensent mais regardez le
l'histoire de la 609 chiffres
l'autoroute oui le tour alors il y a une
auto reconstruire une auto ça coûte cher
une autoroute et ce sera payant et puis
ça relie de ville Castres et Toulouse
bon très bien mais il y a aussi déjà une
route alors cette route on va faire une
quatre voies alors déjà on pourrait dire
comparons mais surtout le projet de
l'autoroute est très ancien et il faut
alors ça peut-être que d'ailleurs dans
les enquêtes dans les dans les dans les
projets il faudrait introduire la date à
laquelle la décision fut prise ou en
visite que le projet était envisagé il
s'est passé des dizaines d'années mais
se passe des tas de choses dans des
dizaines d'années le temps change la
nature change la terre change la
législation change les moyens changent
on n'a pas le discutait pas du
réchauffement climatique il y a des
dizaines d'années dans conditions il ne
faut pas que les élus qui ont validé la
décision ou le projet considère que ils
sont humiliés si c'est le cas non il
faut dire bon allez écouter on dit à la
société très bien s'il faut vous
indemniser on vous indemnisera mais vaut
mieux vous indemniser que de faire une
sottise et puis on va voir si
aujourd'hui c'est adapté et si on peut
pas prendre une autre solution c'est à
dire déjà ça les citoyens devraient en
mesure de dire on fait on revoit en
fonction des circonstances si c'est des
dizaines d'années ça c'est le minimum
qu'on leur doit vraiment c'est le
minimum pour vous dire que il faut un
peu de radicalité pour s'opposer à un
projet c'est un argument de plusieurs
militants qui vous disent de toute façon
s'il y a pas de radicalité le projet
verra le jour après ce qui est forcément
le cas là ça a pas été le café c'est de
la conviction c'était de la conviction
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'origine étymologique de radicalité
c'est les racines et finalement ce que
disait Karl Marx c'est que finalement
être radical c'est prendre les choses à
la racine et je rejoins finalement ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure en disant
pourquoi ce projet finalement n'a ne
s'est pas transformer je sais pas en ZAD
ou en quelque chose de violent c'est
aussi parce que finalement il s'est ce
projet c'est a été réapproprié par les
par les habitants et que finalement il
n'y a pas forcément eu de gens
extérieurs qui sont venus pour combattre
et là où on se dit que la radicalité est
intéressante aujourd'hui la forme
qu'elle prend et on peut le voir ou à
Sainte solide ou dans les autoroutes
c'est qu'on a deux figures presque
mythologiques enfin qui qui coexistent
dans les personnes qui sont un peu
radicales c'est à la fois Antigone ceux
qui s'opposent qui vont dire non et
Narcisse c'est à dire qu'ils sont aussi
extrêmement galvanisés par le fait de
dire non donc il y a aussi une recherche
du clash et de la et de la visibilité
médiatique là le fait que ce soit resté
finalement quelque chose de collectif
authentique portée par les habitants qui
en plus se sont appropriés
techniquesment le sujet c'est aussi
celle succès de ça peut pas être le cas
partout
Thierry baudet mais moi pour le plaisir
du contre-pied j'ai envie de dire que
peut-être aujourd'hui je pense notamment
aux jeunes générations d'une manière
générale peut-être la radicalité c'est
de ne pas prendre à bras le corps la
question des défis environnementaux de
pas prendre à bras le corps la question
d'un certain nombre d'inégalités
auxquelles ils font face ou ou de ou de
s'en emparer j'allais dire isolément et
séparément je parle déjà parce que d'une
manière plus générale ce sont ceux qui
sont qui s'abstiennent le plus les
dimanches d'élection ce sont eux qui
prennent le plus j'allais dire leur
distance vis-à-vis de nos de nos grands
rites démocratiques mais le monde futur
dont on parle ce sont les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui qui l'habiteront et moi je
suis très frappé par exemple que les
jeunes souvent on les associe ou en les
consulte sur les sujets d'orientation de
formation
d'insertion professionnelle mais tous
les sujets de de la ville et concerne et
et ils doivent considérer que c'est tout
à fait radical de ne pas être associé à
la construction du monde futur qui les
habiteront elle vient du Coran
la radicalité tout dépend de de
l'endroit où on se place pour l'observer
je crois c'est juste alors sur la
radicalité moi le monde fait pas peur
je pense que la c'est c'est un problème
de il n'y a pas de grandes choses qui se
font avec des tempéraments tièdes
voilà vous ici vous êtes tous les trois
engagés toute votre vie vous n'êtes pas
tiède d'une certaine manière vous avez
fait des choix radicaux vous avez avec
votre vie décidé de faire des choses que
sinon vous ne feriez pas donc Dieu Jésus
voit il est tiède vous vous souvenez ça
c'est vomissons les tiennes on le fait
alors attention la radicalité c'est à
dire la violence ça veut dire je ne
céderai pas je ne bougerai pas et j'irai
jusqu'au fond une petite frontière avec
l'illégalité c'est ça de toute façon
désobéissance civile c'est illégal c'est
vrai mais toute loi nouvelle bouscule la
loi ancienne c'est déjà la première
chose les premiers radicaux sont les
parlementaires sénateurs et députés ils
sont toujours en train de faire basse
bouleverser les lois excusez-moi c'est
vous les premiers
la deuxième chose et la deuxième chose
c'est peut-être que notamment pour
réfléchir à l'association de la jeunesse
c'est peut-être on pourrait rajouter un
critère dans ses choix à faire sur des
projets c'est à dire le critère de la
croissance démocratique on a vécu des
sociétés qui ont considéré que seule la
croissance éc économique par financière
avait de l'intérêt et nous n'avons pas
introduit le critère de la croissance
démocratique or pour ne pas avoir
intégré le critère de la croissance
démocratique lentement mais sûrement on
fait des périr la démocratie et si par
exemple on disait dans ses projets là je
suis le juge administratif je dois
statuer sur un projet comme sujet et je
vois que la population a été très
associée qu'elle a beaucoup travaillé
vous savez le juge il est pas idiot il
est comme nous il dira mais bien sûr que
je valide un projet pareil compte tenu
de l'importance de l'investissement
démocratique
pour libérer les juges
arrêtons-nous sur cette évolution merci
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis comme chaque semaine à
très vite sur Public Sénat
[Musique]